all right moving on i have a a little
coach's corner segment
rare for you you don't do a lot of
coaches corners i don't i don't uh
i should because it's it's the easiest
stuff to put
but yeah so i i wanted to
um
i wanted to expand
a little bit on
uh
some of the information you covered in
your big goal setting section both from
your article and
from a recent episode of the podcast
and one of the things that i got a fair
number of questions about uh especially
after the article came out is like
people asking like you know i
i understand like part of the goal
hierarchy idea that you were talking
about people saying like i understand
parts of this stuff like the uh the
underlying process goals that underpin
kind of the intermediate goals and how
you can have process goals that support
uh multiple outcome goals and all of
that
but there was a bit of confusion about
what actual practical utility a
superordinate goal had so if you
remember
uh if you remember that podcast episode
or that article basically if you're
setting up a goal hierarchy you have
super ordinance goals at the top which
are kind of
uh
like an underlying value like the thing
that your outcome goals are supporting
so
you know let's say you want to improve
your diet you want to start exercising
more regularly
things like that uh your super ordinane
goal might be related to either getting
healthier or maintaining good health
so that's kind of like the overarching
thing that everything else kind of flows
from
so
um yeah i i got some questions about
like just what is the practical utility
of having a super ordnance goal
and i think one of the i think one of
the big things it does for you
is i see a lot of people
just
you know
across the internet in the stronger by
science groups and reddit and facebook
and whatnot
who will ask questions along the lines
of like you know hey like i don't know
why but like i've been pursuing these
goals and i i just have no motivation
right now what's going on
and often times you kind of you kind of
interrogate that
and you realize that maybe
they
just got it in their head like hey like
trying to get as strong as possible is a
good thing to do for its own sake so
like i'm i'm just gonna do that and
maybe their training is going well but
like they're just having a hard time
staying motivated to keep going to the
gym consistently
and then you kind of interrogate it a
little bit
and you're just like well you know
why do you want to squat 500 pounds like
what what is
underpinning that and oftentimes it's a
question they haven't really even
considered before
um
and then you know they think about it a
little bit more and they're like you
know ultimately i decided i wanted to
start lifting in the first place because
like you know got into my 30s used to be
active when i was younger found myself
out of shape and i said ah you know i'll
go to the gym
and then i met up with some power
lifters and they said oh yeah like this
is fun you should try powerlifting
getting strong very cool uh so i tried
it and then like you know now i see
looking back a couple years later uh i
got into powerlifting and you know i i
fell for the idea that cardio kills your
gains and so you know maybe my overall
activity levels have gone down even even
as i started training uh decided i
wanted to be as good as powerlifting as
possible so
moved up a couple weight classes when
you know maybe that wouldn't have been
uh the best thing to do for body
composition and general health and then
you look back on it and it's like well
you know ultimately like the super
ordinane goal uh if they would have
framed it that way it's still kind of
the same like you know they're still
somewhere in their late 30s and maybe
they have a young family and they're
like you know i want to be healthy like
that's
that's the main thing i'm interested in
and the initial steps they took were
towards that super ordinane goal and
then at some point uh you know it kind
of got diverted and they kept setting
outcome goals that were within the same
general genre as when they first went to
the gym you know have some sort of
quantifiable thing to progress on but
over time
their
like intermediate outcome goals drifted
pretty far away from what the ultimate
thing they cared about was and the
ultimate thing they wanted to accomplish
and to be clear like i'm not just taking
shots at powerlifting here um you know i
see the same thing happen with like
physique athletes all the time like hey
i went to the gym because i wanted to
get healthy and now like i'm six percent
body fat and my hair's falling out and
my dick doesn't work like that's
you know maybe not uh
the most compatible thing with optimal
health so you know i see
stuff like that happen pretty frequently
where
people start losing motivation
and just never
like maybe never really interrogated in
the first place
why they wanted to accomplish what they
wanted to accomplish
um
or you know maybe they did but they they
hadn't really checked up on it in years
and so i think one of the benefits of
having a clear super ordinance goal
is it helps you make sure that the
actual actions you're taking
and the like intermediate quantifiable
goals you're pursuing
are still
in service of that thing you you
ultimately care about i think a lot of
times when people do end up losing
motivation it's because
the actions they're taking and the
intermediate quantifiable goals they're
pursuing
[Music]
are
can become pretty badly misaligned with
the super ordnance goal that they care
about
that that if they would have been more
explicit about like what's driving these
outcome goals maybe they wouldn't have
drifted so far away from it in the first
place and i think that can help
that can help people maintain motivation
like if if your actions and your kind of
underlying drives and motivations are
are better aligned um
so that's just general advice for people
but it's also general advice for like
trainers and coaches because i
i know that that happens all the time
too like you know let's say a client
comes to you and they say like you know
i just want to i want to move better
when i have more energy you're a trainer
and so first place your brain goes it's
like well okay let's let's kind of set
some quantifiable goals like that that
we want to pursue when training this
person so they say they want to move
better they want to have more energy and
so you operationalize that it's like
you know
if we can get this person to be able to
like say do a full squat uh and
like do deep lunges that they can that
they can control pretty well relative to
most of the population that that
qualifies as is moving better and
certainly for
a lot of especially middle-aged clients
relative to their starting point that
would be like clear quantifiable
evidence that they are moving better
and they want to get in better shape so
you say like you know let's let's do
some uh
like let's try to get them in better
aerobic shape and since it's kind of a
personal training setup generally your
time with them isn't very long and so
you're not gonna make them pay for a
session where it's like ah well you're
going to run on the treadmill for an
hour and i'm going to watch you
so you know you have them do some
interval training in the sessions that
you have with them and so you know early
on
those things that you're doing like just
getting them moving doing some intervals
that's that's very much in line with
helping them get more energy and working
on their mobility and their movement
patterns getting them to be able to
squat and lunge well that's very much in
line with their goal of moving better
but then as
time progresses i think
i think it's pretty easy to kind of lose
sight of what those underlying
motivations were in the first place so
you know they
get to the point where they can do a
deep squat and do it well they get to a
point where they can do lunges with body
weight and control it well so the first
place your brain goes as a trainer is
like well you know now we're at the
point of progressive overload like they
can do the exercises wanted them to do
so now let's now let's load them up a
little bit
same thing with the interval training
they start getting in better shape and
it's like well you know let's uh shorten
the rest intervals or push the intervals
a little bit harder or raise the
intensity on them you know whatever just
basic progressive overload
and so you know maybe the first three
months you're working with this client
everything you're doing is very very
much in line with what their goals are
and what they're trying to accomplish
but then you get maybe another six
months down the line and you're training
them as as if they're like a sprint
cyclist uh you know trying to make like
an olympic team or something
and
you know
like they've made a lot of quantifiable
progress but maybe
after you kind of cleared that
three-month mark maybe it's not
necessarily
in line with what they actually wanted
to accomplish and that's something i see
from trainers a lot it's like oh man
like my my clients were making progress
but like they uh they stopped working
with me like their their motivation
seems to be waning but like they're
getting so much stronger or like they're
losing so much weight what's what's
wrong and it's like well
like is is that actually what they
wanted and like sometimes it is and like
clients just suck but
oftentimes i think it is a matter of
just like a
trainer kind of losing sight of what
matters to the client and
you know just over time the the goals
you have set for them and the things
that you're trying to pursue with their
training program maybe drifts away from
the underlying things that actually
matter to the client um so yeah i think
that that's one of the
i think that's that's maybe the biggest
uh practical benefit
of having a clear super ordinane goal
that you know you don't just mention
once and then never really think about
again but that is actually like pretty
close to top of mind a lot of times
especially as you maybe meet a goal and
you're setting a new one just check back
in like
is this super ordinary goal still my
super ordinance goal like maybe have my
underlying
drives and motivation shifted over time
if so that's great if they haven't and
it's still basically the same
are these new
like quantifiable outcome focus goals
i'm setting
actually in line with this underlying
thing that does ultimately matter to me
the most and as long as you keep that in
mind
i i think it
becomes a lot easier to
maintain motivation with the goals you
set for yourself and to take actions
that allow you to follow through
yeah i'm glad you brought this up
because this is something i talk about
with my clients a lot in coaching um
sometimes i'll have clients uh
fortunately not too frequently because
you know in ideal scenarios clients are
loving their training motivation's high
everything's good but every now and then
i will have this conversation with a
client where
you know they'll kind of mention that
motivation has been really low and you
know it's kind of it's not just like i
had a tough week it's it's been weeks of
low motivation
they'll bring that information to me and
i kind of feel like i get the sense that
they're expecting
some tough love
like i'm supposed to say well you gotta
want it bad or something like that you
gotta you gotta tough through it
and that's never been my approach even
before i dug into this literature about
super ordinary goals and things like
that but it's always seemed really
intuitive to me that
if you are sensing low motivation for a
sustained period of time
you don't really have a motivation
problem you don't really have a
willpower problem you have a
misalignment problem like you mentioned
like the issue there is in my opinion oh
we have a dog that entered the room
the issue in my opinion is that
what's happening is like you mentioned
there's some drift going on
and our program now is not currently
facilitating the pursuit of a goal that
is still super important to that
individual and so we need to realign
those things so my first thing is not to
do the whole tough love thing and say
hey you got to pick it up and just do it
i encourage people
take some time to think about you know
what are we doing this for well you know
do we need to reassess what some of our
intermediate goals are do we need to
reassess what our superordinate goal is
and i think finding that alignment
usually sorts out a lot of the
motivation related issues
and another thing i try to get my
clients away from
when they're feeling that that kind of
like low motivation everything that
we're doing is just kind of grinding and
toiling
there are some short-term scenarios
where you do have to grind out some
tough training blocks
but in many cases i think a lot of times
people
they kind of create this dichotomy of
like instant gratification versus
delayed gratification
and some people
adopt so much focus on delayed
gratification
that they don't enjoy a damn minute
of their training career because they're
always like oh no in 20 years when i'm
way stronger like this will all be worth
it and so what i try to get people to
embrace is the idea of
continuous gratification where of course
we're leading towards some kind of goal
that's important to us but like if we
are not enjoying that process and
feeling great about taking the steps
toward it i i just think there's a huge
missed opportunity to really love what
you're doing there so yeah
it seemed like you you disagree with me
no i i don't disagree with you i think
this is this is a one of my spicier
takes i think the whole concept of
delayed gratification is actually
complete [ __ ]
um so you agree with me more than i
thought yeah yeah no i i i don't think
anyone does it
i think that
i think that largely i think everyone is
kind of doing the continuous
gratification thing and i think that a
lot of people
who
swear up and down that they're doing
delayed gratification
were just like talt and acculturated
into a particular mindset
that gives them a little dopamine rush
when they do do something that is
typically associated with delayed
gratification yeah such that they're
actually getting their gratification
yeah in the short term like
you know the the classic example that
people always come back to is like you
know saving your money instead of like
spending it every time your paycheck
hits
and like i used to think that with that
i was doing delayed gratification but
dude my my parents just like drilled
that into my head from day one um
because like they didn't come from
uh
a
uh particularly well-off financial
background and so like for for me and my
brother they just drilled into us from a
very early age like spending all of your
money is bad saving money is good and so
like you know when i when i would save i
used to be like oh i'm doing this good
virtuous thing like i'm delaying
gratification and then i thought about
i'm like no it stresses me out to spend
money and i like saving money like yeah
uh
i don't know like i'm i'm doing the
thing that in the short term makes me
feel good because it was like so drilled
into me at an early age that like no it
like if you spend this money that's bad
so
i don't know i i think that that's
um
i think that that's like a mindset that
my parents instilled in me that's that's
helpful in a lot of ways but there
there's no delayed gratification going
on like
spending that money would stress me the
[ __ ] out like that that would not be
short-term gratification
um
so yeah like i don't know i'm sure that
there's a little bit of that that goes
on but i think that a lot of behaviors
that people associate with with delaying
gratification i think a lot of it is is
motivated
by
just like underlying cultural values
that they were taught and kind of like a
sense of duty and whatnot and so that
like when you do those things it makes
you it makes you feel good because you
think like oh i'm doing the good thing
right now see i think everyone's doing
the continuous gratification thing i
think that's a
a complete a completely [ __ ] and
unhelpful false dichotomy yeah well in
either case you know if you are noticing
that you are
really dragging your feet through
training
whether it's because you're locked into
this concept of delayed gratification or
because you just haven't spent a lot of
time pondering about what your super
ordinary goal truly is
if you find yourself in a position where
your training just feels like a chore
and like a second job that you dread
going to
something is off you should address that
and the recipe to success there is not
more willpower and generating false
motivation because
it probably ain't going to work yeah
definitely not in the long term